martin bureau michel david michel suau
gibbons soir on va le voir sur la courbe
les hospitalisations monde c'est ce qui
inquiète entre autres bon évidemment il
ya les décès ce quand on compare que la
première vague on est rendu à 737
on avait commis un seuil à 7 ça avant
que ne commencent les délestages
important qu'on soit obligé d'annuler
des opérations par ailleurs et depuis
les derniers trois mois
c'est là où ça ou ça pose problème
regarder la coop comme ça va vite
depuis septembre sur le go à 10 ans à
chaque deux mois la safer a doublé pour
arriver à 700 ans et plus martin compte
tenu de sable sur le voie du beige
j'aurais peut-être pas dû annoncer ça il
ya deux semaines mais c'est ça qui est
ça ouais il n'y a jamais de bon moment
en politique pour reculer puis quand on
recule parce que on n'a pas vraiment un
choix vaut mieux choisir son moment
alors il ya quand même plusieurs
facteurs qui font que monsieur legault a
choisi spécifiquement avec son équipe de
faire cette annonce là aujourd'hui
bon d'abord les chiffres parlent d'eux
mêmes et on voyait tous les experts qui
commençaient à sortir publiquement soit
par un tweet soit une lettre ouverte
soit une entrevue pour dire que ça
n'avait pas de bon sens de continuer à
maintenir des rassemblements à noël et
que sa fille ne ferait qu'empirer la
situation
mais plus que ça politiquement la
semaine prochaine ça va être une grosse
semaine pour monsieur legault c'est la
fin de la session parlementaire et judy
la protectrice du citoyen doit déposer
rendre public son rapport d'étape sur la
gestion de la pandémie
lors de la première vague dans les chu
celle des cerises est un caillou dans le
soulier de monsieur leubou alors aussi
bien
passé à faire avaler la pilule cette
semaine sur les annuler noël passer au
prochain problème la semaine prochaine
un caillou plus d'une brique michel
david donc personne était un épi je
pense que vous avez pu entendre les gens
au début de l'émission l'a beaucoup
disait comprendre évidemment oui je
pense que personne d'abord qui surprit
se fait des jours et des jours dans le
fond conçu deux bouts nous prépare pour
cette annonce là je pense que les
raisons que martin a évoqué pour
expliquer pourquoi ça vient plus vite
car on se sont tout à fait valable mais
de toute manière monsieur legault savait
très bien qu'en voyant les chiffres ça
ne peut ça ne peut qu'empirer parce que
la hausse des cas et va inévitablement
ça va se transposer par une hausse des
hospitalisations à terme
alors ça servait à rien de
de tergiverser aussi bien coupé le noeud
tout de suite mais les gens on le voyait
d'ailleurs depuis quelques jours il y
avait un sondage récemment se faisait à
l'idée est plus que ça commence à
trouver que c'était une bonne idée de
prendre air de parenté
alors je pense que les dommages
politiques vont être relativement minime
il reste à voir dans quelle mesure les
gens vont vraiment ne pas faire de part
été parce que il y en a qui étaient pour
tricher des jeux en faisant des plus
gros party meta ils vont peut-être
tricher en faisant des plus petits
partis mais il va y avoir des traits
celui ci invite à aimer vie table va en
avoir moins de rassemblement que si on
avait donné un feu vert pour du
rassemblement j'ouvre une parenthèse on
vient d'avoir les chiffres l'alberta ya
une seconde mais lui 154 cas de plus en
alberta c'est beaucoup pour l'alberta
qui a demandé l'aide du fédéral hier
pour deux hôpitaux de fortune la détente
parce qu'on sait plus où mettre les gens
qui arrivent donc on a besoin d' espaces
alors la flambée au mont la ville en
canada michel c oui les québécois vivent
pas dans une bulle quand et attend des
chutes de l'alberta qu'une population
qui est deux fois moins que celle du
québec disait il c'est grave la bat de
l'ailé genre à te parler du docteur
frautschi la washington qui dit ça fait
pas de rassemblement une réelle et tout
ça alors tout concordait pour que
monsieur legault qui sont aujourd'hui
cinq comme disait michel david sac ça
coûte à gré un prix politique énorme
parce qu'en fait je pense que les gens
voient les chiffres considère honda
expérience de la première vague on sait
que ça peut être très grave que ça peut
devenir exponentielle je pense que les
gens comprennent facilement que des
caprices du premier ministre une
décision qui est amené dans la science
voilà le premier ministre qui donnait
une entrevue avec notre collègue
castonguay dans l'actualité
c'est la question classique composent
année dans les classiques entrevue de
fin d'année lorsque de quelle note vous
vous donnez à ce que j'ai fait une
erreur et tout cela c'était un front
froid on va entendre le jeu bérubé en
chambre qui qui va résumer le petit bout
de l'article qui a fait problème
et monsieur legault à petit très content
puis revenue la tâche a promis qu on lui
a posé la question suivante avez vous
fait une erreur quelque chose que vous
aimeriez refaire différemment sa réponse
je le cite
non je n'en vois pas non je n'en vois
pas le premier ça donc commis aucune
erreur s'est attribué une note parfaite
nous avons le premier ministre parfait
j'ai eu l'occasion d'ailleurs dans cette
entrevue 2d que tous les gouvernements
auraient dû âgés beaucoup plus tôt pour
embaucher plus de préposé dans les ch
celle des et je le dis je le répète
depuis le début depuis neuf mois
j'ai toujours suivi et même fait plus
que ce que la santé publique qu'est
écoutez comme je le disais tantôt je
suis pas parfait j'ai pas de boule de
cristal au moment où j'ai proposé ce
contrat moral là j'étais sincèrement
convaincu que c'était possible
on avait mis ainsi dit si la situation
se détériore port malheureusement la
situation s'est détériorée bon pilote il
m'a dit à ma femme là il va remettre je
ne suis pas parfait et c'est alors à
michel 5
qu'est ce que vous en dites nul n'est
parfait et on sait tous cela dit vous
avez parlé du rapport de la protectrice
du citoyen qui va sortir la semaine
prochaine je pense sûr qu'elle va dire
qu'à gestion de la première bague dans
les seychelles d'hériter parfait loin de
là
et si une chose qui vaut rester à
monsieur legault c'est ce nombre de
morts dans la première vague alors qu'on
n'avait de loin le plus grand nombre de
morts au canada qu'on était même un des
endroits au monde des juridictions
rebondi en avait le plus sens il peut
dire ce que s'il ya ce qui prive
volontairement des mauvaises décisions
non mais était il ya quelques par le
gouvernement n'était pas prêt pour ça
pis je pense que c'est ça que la
protectrice veut dire se le dit est ce
qu'il a essayé de corriger dès qu'il ya
plus oui vous savez quand on est arrivé
c'était un tournant quand même en danse
est dans cette liste d'appui on l'a vu
contre aucune conférence de presse
d'urgence samedi midi et tout ça cela
dit oui quelque part oui il ya eu des
arts parce qu'on on a vu le nombre de
mort des serres chaudes et puis si on
veut pas donner expliqué en conférence
de presse qu'il n'était pas il y aurait
dû être mieux préparée à répondre à
cette question nos classiques
qu'est-ce que vous avez au moins bon
couple mieux préparer le cssd 3 il va
être mieux préparer sa prochaine
françois david
bah oui l'erreur c'est à dire qu'ils
avaient pas faire d'erreur c'est ce même
une erreur de débutant un politicien
aguerri comme monsieur legault le sait
il le savait
il ya bien compris après qu'il n'y avait
pas de dire ça mais honnêtement qui n'en
fait pas les gens vont dire ça y est je
pense un péché véniel dans ce cas ci
mais je comprends que de position fait
des gorges chaudes mais tout le monde
sait que monsieur legault est pas un
inventeur le particulièrement et qui
admet les erreurs d'ailleurs c'est un
peu étonnant parce qu'ils en avaient
déjà admis dans sa gestion de la
pandémie précédemment alors les gens les
ont pas oubliés
mais bon il y aura les jambes on passe à
autre chose a fait leur position si il
ya une chose qui dit par contre dans
l'entrevue c'est quand on lui demande
est ce que la crise va marquer votre
carrière
est il à monsieur legault il dit
j'espère que non mais là je pense qu'ils
se trompent savoir marquer sa carrière
comme comme comme celle de tous les
policiers qui sont au pouvoir la pana
oui martine par ailleurs l'opposition
qui pose depuis quelques jours des
questions entre autres sur est ce qu'on
devrait être plus sévère la ta question
est ce qu on permettait ou pas les deux
rassemblements ça s'est réglé mais par
ailleurs est plus restrictive plus
sévère encore compte tenu des cas la
santé publique n'avait pas comme
n'étaient pas rendus annulé les deux
rassemblements noël où on en est là
dedans mais justement je pense qu'elle
est la décision gouvernementale elle ait
été prise aussi à des fins plus
politique d'agenda politique mais c'est
sûr qu'il y avait un certain malaise
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale la
période des questions étaient
particulièrement dures et monsieur
legault on l'a pas vu souvent comme ça
il y est capable de remettre la monnaie
de sa pièce les partis d'opposition mais
là aujourd'hui
il était quasi assez agressifs les mêmes
en mesure de diversion le pur on voyait
qu'il était ailleurs et cette
question-là locke qui est venu du parti
québécois qui auront le pousser dans les
câbles en disant vous vous êtes vous dit
parfait la salle la hat est clairement
personnellement et il a probablement
créé que ça percole parce que il a amené
dans la conférence de presse et il
voulait s'expliquer sur ce point là je
pense que il s'est rendu compte qu'ils
avaient raté sa réponse et qu'il y
aurait souhaité que ça passe inaperçu
mais là maintenant qui se retrouvait
dans une situation où c'était public il
y a décidé de recadrer de tenter de
recadrer le message mais c'était une
dure journée sur plusieurs points pour
monsieur legault dure semaine parce que
les partis d'opposition sont là et il le
pousse dans les câbles et 9 mois de
pandémie
monsieur legault est quand même seul
c'est quand même lui qui prend les coups
il prend tout l'ensemble dès décisions
pour son gouvernement
bon ottawa dure semaine aussi d'une
certaine façon pour monsieur trudeau qui
doit tenter de répondre avec le plus de
détails possible aux questions sur le
fameux vaccin
combien l'on sait que 6 millions en
principe d'ici la fin mars pour fiber
ces deux doses donc ces trois millions
de canadiens dr tam ky d'hier c'est
insuffisant pour même allé au début de
notre plan de vaccination pour les gens
vulnérables alors un méchant c'est aux
juges commencent avec vos tours de table
vient défi pour monsieur trudeau sérieux
aussi il ya une énorme défi parce qu'il
est allé dire on va avoir assez de
vaccins on a recommandé novak c'est
assez tôt on n'est pas dans les premiers
pays qui vont recevoir lorsqu'on les
produits pommés on est tout de suite
après si ça devait ne pas être exact il
faudrait qu'il répondre de ce qu'il a
dit et il faut pas oublier une chose
c'est on regarde je regardais le plan de
la hague le père sava c'est bien
d'angleterre pas énorme et il n'y a pas
de grandes distances ya une population
relativement concentré ici c'est faut
aller jusque dans le nord il faut aller
d'un océan à l'autre
ça va prendre tout le petit change de
l'armée canadienne pour s'occuper de la
logistique de sauce probablement la
seule organisation capable de s'occuper
de cette régie de cycle a que des
hélicoptères que tout ce qu'il faut il
s'est passé quoi le major général forte
un avion on se pratique à blanc mais ça
va prendre vraiment toutes les
ressources qu'ils ont pour faire ça et
c'est donc dans la logistique dans la
chaîne logistique seul essai de bayonne
plus faibles ces derniers qui est
dangereux
le concierge aurait pas un clip on n'a
pas pu ouvrir la place c'est ça qu'est
le problème celle d'avant depuis le
début de la pandémie on a vu que la loi
de murphy l'accommoder s'est appliqué à
plein
la loi qui dit que ce qui peut aller mal
voilées mal c'est santé ce que ce à quoi
on a assisté depuis depuis neuf mois
alors il n'y a pas de raison de penser
que tout d'un coup tout va tomber dans
la bonne case donc il va y avoir je sais
pas lesquels mais il va certainement y
avoir des bavures des retards des
erreurs et sa voix est inévitablement à
autant de coups pour monsieur trudeau
que l'opposition va va exploiter et il
le fait qu'il n'y ait pas assez de doses
même pour les gens que le gouvernement
juge prioritaire il va à ce moment là
vous avez un des boss à partir du moment
où on raccourcit la lys qui on enlève à
titre alors on peut difficilement le
sortir gagnant de cette opération là
tout ce qui peut espérer c'est que ils y
entrent dans la phase suivante sans être
opaque la paix oui martin palace est la
deuxième force justement parce que les
choses se préparent jusqu'en mars on
sait que les plus vulnérables devraient
être capables d'être être vaccinés mais
après mars là c'est assez nébuleux sur
le prochain lot de doses et il va voir
un travail d'équilibriste parce que
c'est sûrement une partie de la
population qui va être vaccinés mais il
va falloir parler de confinement et de
déconfinement il faut falloir faire
attention pour pas des conflits nés trop
vite pour passant liés sur une troisième
vague et fait du vaccin
c'est de quatre à six semaines afin
qu'ils fassent effet alors il va avoir
un gros travail à faire pour convaincre
les gens d'être patient très bien merci
beaucoup à la prochaine au revoir à très
bientôt vas voir on va revoir